[Music]
hi everyone I'm anne-marie green and I'm
vladimir duthiers thanks for joining us
bloodshed and burials are overshadowing
the new US Embassy in Jerusalem new
protests erupted along the Gaza border
and in the West Bank today Palestinian
demonstrators burned tires and threw
rocks at Israeli soldiers and police
this comes after yesterday's staggering
wave of violence nearly 60 people were
killed and thousands were injured in
deadly protests Holly Williams takes a
closer look at the volatile situation
and we want to warn you that some of the
video can be graphic for some viewers
they carried their dead to be buried
here in Gaza including several children
caught up in the bloodshed more than
1300 people are alive but suffered
gunshot wounds according to Palestinian
officials most of the dead were killed
along the border fence that separates
the tiny poverty-stricken gaza strip
from israel where tens of thousands of
Palestinians held angry demonstrations
yesterday furious after the US Embassy
was moved to Jerusalem Israel responded
with deadly force live ammunition aimed
at those it says got too close to the
fence the Palestinians hope East
Jerusalem will one day be their capital
if they ever get their own state and
they are furious over what they say is
American bias towards Israel against the
Hakam Abu shanab is a financial analyst
and was one of the protesters are you
willing to die here we don't have any
other method that we could use instead
of you know dying is the only way the
Israeli military says it also launched
airstrikes yesterday targeting a camp
run by Hamas the militant group that
controls the Gaza Strip and Israeli
media is reporting that Israel has
threatened to assassinate Hamas leaders
if the violent protests can
and CBS News foreign correspondent Holly
Williams is joining us now from Gaza
Holly take us through the scene today in
the aftermath of yesterday's violence
yeah I think that people here in the
Gaza Strip are quite shocked by the
bloodshed that they saw yesterday I mean
they've been holding these protests now
along the fence that separates Gaza from
Israel for six weeks and they'd been
loss of life up until yesterday around
40 people had been killed Israel had
been criticized for in a quote excessive
use of force
tens of thousands of people went to the
fence yesterday huge numbers but I don't
think anyone was ready to see so many
people dying the death toll according to
officials here is now more than 60 that
includes several children and also an
eight month-old baby a little girl layla
al gondor who died of tear gas
inhalation she was buried today and just
a few minutes earlier we saw two
Palestinian men who were killed
yesterday buried here today at martyrs
Cemetery in the Gaza Strip now there
were more protests planned for today to
mark the 70th anniversary of what
Palestinians called their day of
catastrophe following the founding of
the State of Israel but so far following
the violence yesterday very few
demonstrators have gone up to the border
fence so Holly you've talked to some of
the Palestinians out there a protesting
earlier this is video from yesterday
earlier we were showing what was
happening in Ramallah today they're a
long way from Jerusalem where the US
Embassy was opening up what is their
endgame here what are they hoping to
accomplish yeah I mean I think the
Palestinians generally and specifically
who live here in the Gaza Strip want a
lot of things they want their own state
they want the capital of their their
state to be East Jerusalem which is part
of the reason that they are so furious
about the u.s. moving its embassy to
Jerusalem these protests initially when
they began about six weeks ago were
terms the great march of return and the
idea was that Palestinians who live here
in Gaza want to return to lands that
their families fled in 1948 after the
founding of the State of Israel there
are about two million people living here
in Gaza and two-thirds of them are
either refugees or their descendants I
think there are more general
frustrations as well specifically here
in guards are where they've you know
they've experienced a blockade now for
more than ten years and they have a
whole host of problems including
contaminated water power cuts really
high unemployment at nearly 50% and
shortages of goods I think the problem
though is that these protests are
certainly an opportunity for
Palestinians to vent their frustration
but arguably they don't really do
anything for the Palestinians I mean
most of the Palestinian protesters are
peaceful those that are violent are
largely armed with rocks and slingshots
and a burning tires now they don't
inflict any serious damage on Israel and
they don't necessarily sway world
opinion and arguably they only serve to
alienate opinion in Israel even further
Holly yesterday the White House deputy
spokesperson Raj Shah called the
responsibility for violence he said it
rested squarely uploading him now
squarely with Hamas even though nearly
most of the Palestinians that have been
killed over the last couple of weeks
have been killed through Israeli live
fire launching air strikes as you've
seen over the last couple of days
explain the significance of Hamas we had
a spokesperson from the Israeli
government here on cbsn yesterday she
very much said the same thing that Raj
Shah said she also said that the that
Hamas does not provide any services for
people living in the Gaza Strip but back
in 2007 when they won the special
elections against the secular
photography they were promising people
that they were going to make their lives
better have they
I think it's been very difficult for
them to make people's lives better here
when the Gaza Strip has been suffering
the effects of this blockade I mean to
be clear Hamas is an Islamist militant
group that's been in power here in the
Gaza Strip since 2007 they weren't the
original instigators of these protests
as we understand it but they certainly
have encouraged them they've certainly
supported them and I suppose some would
argue that they've done so cynically
because they think that they if they
encourage Palestinians to go and protest
at the border fence some of them will be
killed by Israelis and that might go
some way to swaying public opinion in
their favor but remember also that
though Israel says that it has been
acting in self-defense others have
criticized it for what they see as an
excessive use of force and in fact the
UN has criticized what happened
yesterday as appalling deadly violence
Polly Williams thank you so much